which function
increases as x increases toward infinity
and decreases
as x decreases toward negative infinity
so let's think about each of these
constraints so first which function
increases as x increases so it's x
increases toward infinity so x is going
in that direction
so first let's look at f of x over here
so f of x as we get beyond this minimum
point right over here as we increase our
x f of x seems to be increasing so f of
x seems to make the first constraint now
think about g of x
once we get past this minimum point
right over here as x gets larger and
larger and larger as it approaches
infinity g of x seems to be getting
larger and larger and larger g of x is
moving up so g of x also seems to make
this first constraint now let's think
about h of x as x moves towards infinity
as x moves towards positive infinity h
of x seems to be decreasing h of s seems
to be decreasing so h of x does not even
make the first constraint so only two
possibilities are now g of x and f of x
so which of these decrease as x
decreases toward negative infinity so
let's think about that x decreasing
toward negative infinity we're going to
be going in that direction
so first let's look at f of x so f of x
it kind of goes up and down here but
after we hit this little local minimum
point this was a local maximum point
this was a local minimum point over here
not a global one as we move to the left
of this low of this local maximum point
as we get smaller and smaller x's we see
that the function is decreasing so it
does seem to meet the second constraint
it decreases as x decreases toward
negative infinity so it meets that
constraint now what about g of x
after we have this minimum point and
actually it looks like a global minimum
point after we hit this minimum point
right over here as x decreases toward
negative infinity g of x seems to be
increasing not decreasing so g of x does
not meet does not meet the second
constraint so the only function that met
both constraints seems to be
f x